à la fin de mai 1958 le 16e président du
conseil de la quatrième république
pierre pflimlin investi quelques jours
plus tôt et victimes du soulèvement de
l'armée et des français d'algérie se
trouve affaiblie au moment où il faut
affronter des tâches de plus en plus
redoutable
en conséquence j'ai présenté ma
démission
miné par la lutte des partis et
l'impuissance des gouvernements
successifs la quatrième république un
gone is c'est l'appel au général de
gaulle qui quitte la boisserie où il
s'était retiré
voilà plus de dix ans le 30 mai 1958 le
président coty propose au général de
gaulle de devenir président du conseil
le général accepte à condition de
disposer des pleins pouvoirs pour six
mois et de pouvoir préparer une
constitution qui sera soumise au
référendum dans son gouvernement entre
notamment guy mollet pierre pflimlin et
paul reynaud 17 jours après avoir confié
à pierre film la direction du
gouvernement
les mêmes députés investissent par 329
voix contre 224 le général de gaulle et
lui accordent les pouvoirs constituants
bien décidés à redonner au pays des
institutions qui lui permettent de
s'affirmer
le général de gaulle donne la priorité à
la mise en oeuvre de la nouvelle
constitution qui doit assurer la
continuité de l'état
le régime est parlementaire mais avec un
chef d'état doté de grands pouvoirs
exécutifs qui est élu par un collège
élargi par 81% des voix la france
approuvera cette constitution ce
référendum du 28 septembre est un vote
de confiance à de gaulle qui au cours de
son mandat faudra sans cesse légitimité
sur le dialogue avec l'opinion par la
pratique du référendum employés pour
toutes les grandes questions puis en
novembre élections législatives le parti
gaulliste u n est recréé le mois
précédent fait entrer au palais bourbon
plus de députés que n'en avait jamais
compté aucun vous parlementaire
le 21 décembre le général de gaulle est
élu comme président de la vème
république son gouvernement dirigé par
michel debré pour à des structures
neuves avec des ministères inédits comme
celui des affaires culturelles par
exemple
[Musique]
monsieur le président de la rép
premier des procès
est désormais le premier enfant
je suis fier de lui remettre la charge
de cette maison capital et d'avoir ainsi
l'occasion de lui renouveler
l'hommage qu'en y entrant j'avais tenu à
lui rendre au nom de la patrie à jamais
votre connexion il s'agit pour de gaulle
en premier lieu de régler le problème de
l'algérie où la guerre se poursuit
depuis quatre ans et a déjà fait des
dizaines de milliers de victimes
la guerre coûte à la france le tiers de
son budget cinq cent mille soldats sont
sur place la durée du service militaire
et de près de 30 mois sur le plan
diplomatique le drame algérien a
totalement isolé la france
en octobre 1958 le général de gaulle
offre à l'algérie pour son développement
économique et social le plan de
constantine le 16 septembre 1959 il
ouvre la voie de l'autodétermination
laissant aux algériens le choix entre la
francisation la sécession et
l'association
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'armée qui a fondé son action sur le
maintien de la souveraineté française
est profondément troublé les épreuves ne
manquent pas en janvier 1960
alger connaît la semaine des barricades
à la suite du rappel du général massu
l'opinion métropolitaine soutient le
général de gaulle les plats pouvoir lui
sans voter
[Musique]
en janvier 1961 c'est le référendum sur
l'autodétermination qui donne 75 % de
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 21 avril les généraux salan challe
jour et zeller déclenché un putsch
après quatre jours d'illusions et
d'agitation un discours général de
gaulle fit tomber les armes des mains
des officiers rebelles pouvoir
insurrectionnel s'est établi en algérie
par un pronom sia manteau militaire
ce pouvoir à une apparence un quarteron
de généraux en retraite
il a une réalité un groupe d'officiers
partisans ambitieux et pas natiq ce
groupe et ce quarteron possède un
savoir-faire limitée expéditif mais il
ne voit et ne connaissent la nation et
le monde que des formes et au travers de
leur frénésie leur entreprise ne peut
conduire qu un désastre national
la france l'andorre que tous les moyens
jeudi tous les moyens soient employés
par pour barrer la route à ces hommes là
en attendant de les réduire
j'ai interdit à tout français est
d'abord à tout soldat d'exécuter aucun
de leurs ordres
l'ouest a paré le terrorisme se pratique
des deux côtés et fallen et aux as le 20
mai s'ouvre la première conférence
d'evian qui aboutira aux accords du 19
mars 1962 avec le fln il proclame le
cessez-le-feu et à cordes diverses
garanties aux européens
là
le terrorisme au rsa gagner la métropole
où les nuits bleues alternent avec les
assassine la petite delphine renard est
grièvement blessé par une explosion dans
la maison d'andré malraux
l'algérie est à feu et à sang
bab el-oued s'érigeant fort chabrol
contre l'armée le 26 mars c'est la
fusillade devant la grande poste à alger
véritable hécatombe le référendum sur
les accords d'evian donne le 8 avril 90
% de oui l'eau as après les avoir
interdit précipité départ c'est l'exode
des français d'algérie qui seront dans
la grande majorité rapidement assimilé à
la communauté métropolitaine
[Musique]
le général de gaulle appel pour succéder
à michel debré un de ses proches
collaborateurs georges pompidou le
gouvernement comptait jusque là
plusieurs dirigeants du mrp en mai 1962
il quitte le gouvernement à la suite
d'un désaccord sur la politique
européenne
le 22 août 1962 alors que pour la
première fois depuis 25 ans la france
est en paix le général et madame de
gaulle échappe par miracle à un attentat
de gaulle en tirent les conséquences
politiques
les attentats qui ont été perpétrés et
ceux qui font qu'ils sont préparés faut
voir que ma disparition risquerait de
replonger la france dans la confusion de
la guerre et bientôt dans la catastrophe
je crois que quoi qu'il arrive la nation
doit avoir le moyen de choisir elle-même
son président afin que cette investiture
direct puisse lui donner la force et
l'obligation d'être le guide de la
france est le garant de l'état
en dépit de la coalition de tous les
partis le référendum constitutionnel du
18 octobre donne 61 % de voix pour le
oui
désormais le président de la république
sera l'élu de tous
[Applaudissements]
élections législatives en novembre 2 133
députés umr entre à la chambre depuis
son arrivée au pouvoir le général de
gaulle avait rendu visite au moins une
fois à chaque département français en
1965 c'est l'élection présidentielle a
décidé unanimement de soutenir la
candidature de françois mitterrand en
tant que candidat d'union de tous les
partis de gauche et organisations
démocratiques sans exclusive devenu le 9
septembre candidat unique de la gauche
françois mitterrand affronte jean lecanu
et le centriste jean louis tixier
vignancour l'avocat
pierre marcilhacy le sénateur et la
candidature isolée de marcel barbu de
gaulle lui n'annonce que le 4 novembre
qu'il sera candidat au premier tour le 5
décembre
participation record 15% d'abstentions
seulement 10,5 millions de voix pour le
général de gaulle 7,6 millions pour
françois mitterrand
[Musique]
au second tour le résultat est net
le général de gaulle l'emportent avec
55% des suffrages contre 45 % à françois
mitterrand le second septennat commence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
en mars 1967 élections législatives les
communistes gagne 32 sièges et la
fédération 25 lui nerfs et républicains
indépendants des passes d'une seule voix
la majorité absolue
plusieurs ministres ont été battus
[Musique]
mais
ce georges pompidou est en premier
ministre le gouvernement et remanié par
l'installation de louis joxe à la
justice alain peyrefitte à l'éducation
nationale et christian fouchet à
l'intérieur 1968 sera une année cruciale
la première fois que nous voyons ça leur
va dire que je fais ici nous occupe pour
l'instant buzz
en mai la révolte d'une minorité
d'étudiants contestataires se propage
comme une traînée de poudre entraîne les
ouvriers à cesser le travail et paralyse
le pays
nul n'a oublié comment la fermeture de
nanterre celle de la sorbonne les heures
et les bagarres ont débouché sur les
barricades du quartier latin puis sur le
déchaînement des violences
[Musique]
et
c'est la grande manifestation de la
gauche le 13 mai la grève bientôt
généralisée
les drapeaux rouges et noirs
l'occupation des bâtiments
universitaires de nombreux lieux de
travail dans la paralysie des organes de
l'état et de la vie du pays le spectre
de la guerre civile a paré le chef de
l'état redresse le 30 mai en s'adressant
quatre minutes à la nation par radio une
situation qui paraissait désespérée
dans les circonstances présentes je ne
me retirerai pas j'ai un mandat du
peuple
je leur empire et je ne changerai pas le
premier ministre jeudi sous aujourd'hui
l'assemblée nationale un million de
personnes définir sur les champs elysées
après l'allocution présidentielle mais
était terminée
[Musique]
les élections législatives fille
rentrait d'un seul coup au
palais-bourbon plus de députés élus sous
la même étiquette qu'aucune chambre n'en
avait jamais comporté 358 gaulliste
maurice couve de murville remplace
georges pompidou à l'hôtel matignon
[Musique]
edgar faure fait voter par un parlement
unanime le 13 novembre
la loi d'orientation universitaire qui
bouleverse les structures de
l'université traditionnelle en accordant
aux étudiants la participation à la
gestion et aux décisions
elle met la france en ce domaine à
l'avant garde des pays modernes
[Musique]
non
au sénat gaston monnerville est remplacé
par alain poher
pendant ce temps c'est à la
participation que se consacre le général
de gaulle il prépare un référendum sur
la régionalisation
[Musique]
l'avènement de la région comme cadre
nouveau de l'initiative du conseil et de
l'action pour tout ce qui touche
localement à la vie pratique du pays
voilà donc à grandes réformes que nous
devons apporter à la france pour que
cette innovation se réalise au plan de
la nation comme au plan de la région
nous devons transformer sénat afin
qu'ils associent dans la préparation des
lois les mêmes sortes d u et les mêmes
sorties de délégués avec leurs
compétences et leurs responsabilités
comme cette profonde réforme concerne
l'organisation de nos pouvoirs publics
dans tous les domaines y compris celui
de la constitution nous devons soumettre
le projet au peuple
convaincu de l'importance de ces
réformes pour le développement de la
france
le général de gaulle met encore une fois
son mandat en jeu dans la bataille de ce
nouveau référendum
[Musique]
1958 1969
ces onze années ont été pour l'économie
française
la période des grandes mutations en 11
ans aucun secteur n'a échappé que ce
soit le secteur industriel où le secteur
agricole mais la remise en ordre de
l'économie puis sa transformation ne se
sont pas toujours faite sans heurts sans
réticence
ainsi dans l'agriculture l'application
des réformes a bien souvent provoqué le
mécontentement des paysans
malgré les difficultés malgré les
longues nuits de négociations de
bruxelles l'europe verte a tout de même
vu le jour et depuis juin 1968 90% de la
production agricole française sont
soumis au régime communautaire mais cela
n'a été possible que grâce à une
transformation radicale de notre
agriculture par l'amélioration des
structures foncières l'organisation de
la production et des marchés
l'amélioration des conditions de vie et
de travail de l'exploitant
[Musique]
les lois d'orientation de 1960 et 2009
162 sont certainement les deux pièces
maîtresses de ces réformes qui ont
permis de transformer l'agriculture tout
en l'insérant dans l'économie générale
du pays
[Musique]
des mutations également dans d'autres
secteurs celui du charbon par exemple
ces lacs éclate en 1963 le premier grand
conflit social de la vème république
lorsqu après l'échec de contact entre la
direction et les syndicats des
charbonnages les mineurs sont
réquisitionnés la grève est totale dans
les bassins elle dure trente quatre
jours et se termine par la signature
d'un accord qui prévoit de nombreux
avantages sociaux pour la profession en
raison de la concurrence d'autres formes
d'énergie en raison aussi de son
exploitation coûteuse
le charbon a vu sa production diminuer
d'année en année c'est là un phénomène
mondial
deux conséquences pour notre pays la
situation nouvelle des régions
concernées principalement le nord pas de
calais et la lorraine
l'avenir des mineurs ils étaient 200
3000 en 1958 ils n'étaient plus que
131000 en 1976 une raison majeure aux
conflits sociaux l'emploi et la montée
du chômage en raison notamment du
progrès technique et des regroupements
d'entreprises entre autres mesures
citons l'effort accompli dans le domaine
de la formation professionnelle et en
juillet 67
les importantes ordonnance sur l'emploi
dans le mérite principal a été de
substitué à la notion d'assistance
la notion d' assurance collective
[Musique]
un remède aux conflits sociaux selon le
général de gaulle la participation
troisième voie entre socialisme et
capitalisme le 17 août 1967 trois
ordonnances organise l'intéressement des
salariés aux fruits de l'expansion des
entreprises printemps 68 la relance
économique commence à porter ses fruits
les finances sont saines
la monnaie solide l'économie sortie du
plan de stabilisation se porte bien
un seul point noir l'emploi avec surtout
le chômage des jeunes
agitation des étudiants chômage des
jeunes la convergence des deux problèmes
a lieu le 11 mai lorsqu après huit jours
d'agitation universitaires commencent
les premiers mouvements sociaux les plus
violents depuis 30 ans fin mai tandis
que l'on fait la queue dans les magasins
tandis que malgré tout les grévistes
continuent de distribuer l'électricité
et le gaz
les banques sont fermées l'argent manque
la france est paralysée
le gouvernement offre le dialogue
le 25 mai c'est grenelle gouvernement
patronat et syndicats négocient 25
heures de discussions et la plupart des
revendications sont satisfaites
mais ce n'est là qu'un accord cadre
les avantages acquis devront être
négociés branche par branche et les
lendemains de grenelle déchantent la
base ne suit pas elle décide de
continuer la grève et ce n'est qu'après
l'intervention personnelle du général de
gaulle 30 mai que le dégel intervient le
9 juin minuit la campagne électorale
peut s'ouvrir normalement le travail
reprend l'économie redémarre mais le
malaise social va renaître avec
l'opération riz double elle s'est
déclenchée par les commerçants et les
artisans
en quelques années le petit commerce
français s'est profondément modifiée
l'apparition puis la multiplication des
supermarchés ont transformé son visage
traditionnelle ainsi à l'ouverture des
grandes surfaces s'est bien vite
superposer le problème de l'organisation
même des commerçants indépendants le
gouvernement réponde à leurs inquiétudes
en prenant le 16 avril le jour même de
leur deuxième grève une série de mesures
sociales et fiscales destinées à
faciliter leur adaptation aux exigences
du monde moderne réformes de structure
rénovation en profondeur mutation grâce
à elle et malgré les conflits qu'elles
ont parfois entraîné l'économie
française a pu jouer pleinement la carte
de l'expansion ainsi nos échanges avec
l'étranger se sont accrues dans de très
fortes proportions spécialement avec nos
partenaires européens
l'effort de l'état s'est aussi traduit
par une action continue qui a rendu
notre industrie compétitive sur les
marchés internationaux
l'équipement des ménages a progressé
avec cependant de sensible retard sur le
logement des biens peut diffuser il y a
dix ans sont entrés dans les foyers 70
ménages sur 100 possède maintenant un
réfrigérateur contre 20 il y a dix ans
l'équipement en automobiles et machines
à laver a doublé le mode de vie des
français
c'est en 11 ans profondément transformé
[Musique]
à mesure que monte le niveau de notre
prospérité
nous faisons en sorte que ses élèves
le pouvoir d'achat des français qui
s'est accru en moyenne en huit ans de
30% et nous tâchons que s'améliorent les
conditions générales de leur vie la
sécurité sociale l'aide familiale
l'instruction l'équipement dans son
ensemble les retraites la santé et
cetera toutes choses dont le coût s'est
accru en huit ans de 65% axé sur
l'expansion la politique économique
elle a été aussi et surtout sur la
stabilité de la monnaie
principal objectif dès 1958 dans ce
domaine renflouer les caisses du pays
avec comme échéance principal le 1er
janvier 1959 date du démarrage du marché
commun pour faire face à la concurrence
de nos voisins européens le gouvernement
prépare et publié un plan le 27 décembre
1958 le plan ruef pinet qui comporte la
suppression du franc guy anciens et son
remplacement par un nouveau franc le
franc lourd une dévaluation fixé à 14 95
% à partir du 29 décembre orthodoxie
monétaire mais aussi rigueur budgétaire
afin que la dévaluation soit une
véritable base de redressement
le gouvernement décide un effort
d'austérité mesures qui créent des leurs
applications un climat de confiance et
qui permettent aussi de rembourser par
anticipation les dettes du pays
sur les marchés financiers le franc est
de plus en plus apprécié est considérée
précédemment comme l'une des monnaies
les plus vulnérables il devient une
monnaie forte
le but fixé dans le domaine monétaire
est atteint 12 septembre 1963 nouvelle
étape avec le plan de stabilisation le
plan pompidou giscard d'estaing depuis
le printemps la masse monétaire augmente
les prix montent et les salaires suivent
le mouvement
l'inflation guette équilibre budgétaire
et actions sur les prix seront donc
respecté jusqu'en 1966 mais après la
crise du printemps 1968 une nouvelle
menace pèse sur le franc conséquences de
la fuite des capitaux vers l'étranger à
l'automne l'expansion est revenu mais
pas la confiance
la france recevra une aide
internationale
en échange d'une dévaluation tel est en
novembre la proposition de nos
partenaires
[Musique]
chacun attend cette dévaluation mais ce
n'est pas l'avis du chef de l'état tout
bien pesé
j'ai avec le gouvernement décide et que
nous devons achever de nous reprendre
sans recourir à la dévaluation
poursuivant le même but celui de la
rénovation de l'économie une part
importante des préoccupations étaient
regroupés sous le nom nouveau
d'aménagement du territoire
aménagement de la province aménagement
aussi de la région parisienne
dernière initiative spectaculaire le
transfert des halles du coeur à
l'extrême périphérie de la région
parisienne
cette année de travail et les 13
hectares des halles de paris sont
devenues 204 au début de mars dernier à
rungis
cette année pendant lesquelles quatre
millions de mètres cubes de terre ont
été retournés
une infrastructure complète mise en
place pour que les nouvelles halles de
paris soit vraiment ce gigantesque et
moderne magasin capable de nourrir
chaque jour 10 millions de personnes
capables surtout de répondre en 1990 à
la demande de 12 millions d'habitants
[Musique]
décentralisation mobilité de l'emploi
restructuration extension d'activité
formation professionnelle autant
d'éléments qui interviennent dans la
politique d'aménagement du territoire
dont l'ambition est de développer les
régions et de remédier à la croissance
de paris l'aménagement du territoire et
l'action régionale
c'est par exemple la transformation du
littoral languedoc roussillon futur
californie française c'est
l'aéronautique regroupait à toulouse
confirmant ainsi la vocation de cette
métropole
[Musique]
il reste devant nous une question
essentielle au premier chef
comme elle est profondément humaine
économique et nationale celle là aussi
comment ne pas venir
il s'agit de la condition des
travailleurs au sein de l'activité
économique quand ils font partie que ce
soit au niveau des industries ou au
niveau de la nation le changement qu'il
faut apporter à la condition ouvrière
c'est l'association active du travail à
l'oeuvre économies qu'ils contribuent a
accompli mais il reste à fixer et voies
et les moyens par lesquels est également
la part des travailleurs et du même coup
leur responsabilité dans les progrès des
entreprises seront définies étant donné
qu'ils y ont participé qu'ils y
participent par leur effort et par leur
capacité
[Musique]
l'indépendance nationale le droit des
peuples à décider librement de leur
destin tels sont les principes qui
guideront la politique étrangère du chef
de l'état d'une façon immédiate et
directe pour la france cela s'appelle la
décolonisation l'autodétermination et
l'indépendance des républiques
africaines et malgaches
[Musique]
dès 1958 la guinée se sépare de la
france
les autres nations utiliseront en 1960
la procédure constitutionnelle l'aide et
la coopération librement établi remplace
aujourd'hui la colonisation
on
la coopération c'est pour de gaulle le
meilleur moyen de mettre un terme à la
rivalité des blocs telle qu'elle existe
lorsque se réunit la très brève
conférence de paris
[Musique]
e
la division des peuples qui habitent
l'europe et l'amérique du nord
elle a donné principal est le pire mal
de notre époque deux camps se dresse
face à face dans des conditions telles
qu'il ne dépend que de moscou ou de
washington une grande partie de
l'humanité
soit écrasé en quelques heures
[Musique]
clé de voûte de l'indépendance nationale
la force de dissuasion
la france doit pour faire respecter son
indépendance se doter d'un armement
nucléaire
nous avons pris la route et nous suivons
notre plan l'effort
[Musique]
de recherche d'invention de réalisation
que comportent par lui-même l'armement
atomique introduit dans notre vie
scientifique technique et industrielle
un ferment très efficace
nous voici arrivés au stade des
résultats
ainsi s'ouvre devant nous la perspective
une carrière de dissuasion parce que
attaquer la france
[Musique]
pour qui que ce soit cela reviendrait à
subir et destruction épouvantable
[Musique]
avec la campagne d'expérimentation du
pacifique le lancement du redoutable et
le développement des vecteurs aérien la
france franchit les différents stades de
l'équipement atomique et de
l'utilisation opérationnelle de l'armé
nucléaire
[Musique]
la france si elle considère
qu'aujourd'hui encore il est utile à sa
sécurité et à celle de l'occident
qu'elle soit l'allier d'un certain
nombre d'états et notamment de
l'amérique pour leur défense et pour la
sienne dans le cas d'une agression
commise contre l'un d'entre eux si la
france tient la déclaration d'intention
qui donna lieu à l'alliance atlantique
conclu le 4 avril 1949 à washington
si la france tient cette déclaration
d'intention cette alliance
toujours pour valable elle reconnaît en
même temps que les dispositions
d'application qui ont été prises
successivement et par la suite ne
répondent plus à ce qu'elle juge
en ce qui la concerne satisfaisant dans
les conditions nouvelles conséquences de
la nouvelle politique française pour qui
allianz militaires et politiques sont
deux choses distinctes
l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique-nord quitte la france pour
la belgique
les troupes alliées des ménages
phnom penh sur le sol asiatique
le général de gaulle condamne l'
escalade entreprises par washington au
vietnam
[Musique]
à la considère que les combats qui
ravagerait dauchy n'apporte par
eux-mêmes et eux n'ont plus aucune issue
suivante elle s'il est invraisemblable
que l'appareil guerrier américain puisse
jamais être anéantie sur place d'autre
part il n'y a aucune chance pour que les
peuples de l'asie se soumettre à la loi
d'un étranger venu de l'autre rive du
pacifique
quelles que puissent être ses intentions
et quelle que soit la puissance de césar
bref si l'on dit du que doivent être
encore l'épreuve il est certes un rose
yeux de la france qu'elle n'aura pas de
solution militaire
répondant à l'espoir général la
conférence de la paix s'ouvre à paris en
mai 1968 pour la procédure en deux les
représentants des deux parties nous
sommes mis d'accord pour que la première
réunion officielle des représentants des
deux gouvernements des états unis
d'amérique aura lieu le lundi prochain
13 mai à 10h30
mais les combats un an plus tard
continue la conférence également
chanteur
on axe man des x games
oui autre aspect de la politique
asiatique de la france la reconnaissance
en 1964 de la chine communiste
pékin et paris sont convenus d'échanger
les ambassadeurs en nouant avec ce pays
avec cet état des relations officielles
comme un autre nation libre l'an fait
auparavant et comme nous l'avons fait
avec d'autres pays qui subissent des
régime analogue
la france ne fait que reconnaître le
monde tel qu'il est mais il se peut
aussi que dans l'immense évolutions
actuelles du monde en multipliant les
contacts directs de peuple à peuple on
servent la cause des hommes c'est à dire
celle de la sagesse du progrès de la
paix en 1964 aussi le mexique et
quelques mois plus tard dix nations
d'amérique latine reçoivent la visite du
chef de l'état français qui souligne le
rôle et l'importance de ces pays en voie
de développement
menacé par telle ou telle hégémonie
politique ou économique
[Applaudissements]
équipe nocquet el pueblo frances repos
hne
elles pointent de lomé chicane au marché
mousse la mano en la mano y viva mexico
[Musique]
en 1967 au milieu d'une foule en délire
c'est l'inoubliable voyage au canada le
québec qui fait partie de la grande
famille francophone signe avec la france
de multiples accords de coopération la
minorité française du canada
doit-elle aussi voir ses droits reconnus
et ennemi la france entière c'est quoi
ce qui se passe ici au drame le montréal
québec
[Applaudissements]
relation franco allemande ce jeu c'est
là peut-être que la transformation et la
plus spectaculaire la réconciliation et
le rapprochement avec le chancelier
adenauer aboutissent en 1964 à la
signature du traité de coopération qui
demeure un événement historique
[Musique]
oh
l'europe des six pendant ce temps
célèbre son 10e anniversaire en 1958 la
politique européenne n'existe et surtout
dans les textes de gaulle va en faire
une réalité
il prend les mesures nécessaires pour
assurer l'intégration de l'économie
française dans la communauté européenne
le calendrier du traité de rome est
respectée les discussions ont été
longues et difficiles
mais l'europe des six existent sur le
plan économique du moins il reste à
faire l'europe politique au sein de
laquelle les nations doivent selon le
général de gaulle coopérer tout en
conservant leur indépendance
quant à l'entrée de la grande bretagne
dans le marché commun à deux reprises le
chef de l'état la rejette
non sans être longuement expliqué
et de savoir si la grande bretagne
actuellement peut se placer avec le
continent et comme lui à l'intérieur
d'un tarif qui soit véritablement commun
de renoncer à toute préférence à l'égard
du commonwealth de cesser de prétendre
que son agriculture soit privilégiée est
encore de tenir pour caduques les
engagements qu'elle a pris avec les pays
qui ont fait partie du faisait partie ou
qui font partie de sa zone de libre
échange
cette question là c'est toute la
question
on ne peut pas dire qu'elle soit
actuellement résolu est-ce qu'elle sera
un jour seul évidemment
l'angleterre peut répondre la
multiplication des rapports avec
l'europe de l'est se traduit par de
nombreux accords et contribuer à la
détente internationale rapport dans les
domaines économique culturel
scientifique dont dépend leur propre
développement
mais encore d'échanger leurs ovules et
je l'espère
concerter leurs actions en vue d'aider à
l'union et à la sécurité notre continent
ainsi qu'elle est qu'ils y opposeraient
et à la paix du monde tout entre eux
au proche orient où la guerre est une
menace permanente
le général de gaulle lance des appels à
la modération il condamne l'attitude
d'israël en juin 1967 lors de la guerre
des six jours et après les représailles
israéliennes contre l'aéroport de
beyrouth il mais l'embargo sur les
fournitures d'armes
ce qui ne manque pas de provoquer de
nombreuses réactions à travers le monde
à l'affrontement dit le général de
gaulle doit se substituer la
concertation
[Musique]
à l'initiative de la france les
représentants des quatre grands vont se
rencontrer à new york pour essayer de
trouver une solution au problème du
proche-orient et préserver la paix
[Applaudissements]
conséquence logique de la position
française au sein de l'alliance
atlantique et des nouveaux rapports avec
les pays de l'est
la modification des relations franco
américaines celle ci passant par
diverses phases marquée notamment par
l'attitude française envers la
prédominance du dollar et l'hégémonie
américaine au sein du monde occidental
mais en 1968 les liens se resserrent à
nouveau ce rapprochement est confirmée
un peu plus tard lors de l'arrivée de
richard nixon à la maison blanche et le
président américain déclare de gaulle
crois que l'europe doit être
indépendante
franchement je le croise aussi
dernière manifestation officielle et
internationales du président de la
république française dimanche 30 mars
1969 le voyage à washington pour un
ultime adieu à un vieux compagnon
d'armes de tous les héros de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
un seul vit encore aujourd'hui symbole
d'un passé in ou mia
[Musique]